let's get started we'll
we'll cut right to the chase how did it
go
on the exam
i crushed that i heard i crushed that
yeah look at that
so um so you guys
rocked it on exam one and i'm very proud
of you and i'm i
i think this is awesome um
the average was actually really high
which is which is great it means to me
that you guys
have learned the materials that we want
you to learn in the first third of this
class
now if um
if there but you know this is also a
chance that if you if you didn't
you know get up into this range and
you're here or they're down here even if
you're up here and there are a couple of
problems you didn't quite
get this is the the time to go back and
say
what did i miss right how did i
misinterpret or how did i
what did i miss and go back over it now
right and solidify this knowledge
why because
of what's coming next and
and and i i really want to contextualize
this with something really important
um to me and that's bread
now um i say
if you want to get the best bread in
town you go to brico
all right and i really actually strongly
encourage you all to go to brico because
it's true it's really the best bread in
town
um there's frank he's he he founded
brico it's in the south end it's amazing
but now you notice his ingredients
there's only seven ingredients
in in the bread at brico there's
salt right yeast water
uh there's uh anybody know what farina
is
flour okay kruska it's like kind of
wheat stuff
right uh oil and passion
passionate it's the thing he's holding
that's ingredient number seven at brico
which is the best bread in town now
here's my point
i need you guys to to keep bringing the
passion
to this class you should be bringing the
passion to everything you do
because that's what we do at mit right
that's how we approach
everything we do but i need you not to
say well i did really well in exam one
and now i can kind of phone it in
that's not the time to do it trust me
because now
we're going into the next phase the next
third a little bit less than a third of
the class where
we're going to come maybe out of some of
our comfort zones
all right so some of you have seen a lot
of the material that we've already
covered some of you haven't um and
some of you may have seen some of the
material we're about to cover in the
next week or two shape some molecules
molecular orbital theory hybridization
but then we're going to go into crystals
and we're going to take molecular
orbitals and we're going to make
solid orbitals out of them which are
called bands
which is going to give us semiconductors
and we're going gonna dope those with
chemistry
all sorts of stuff so keep up the
passion
please that's why it's showing you
frank and brico keep up the passion
okay now today um we're going to cover
a really important follow-up to lewis
which is how to how to predict
what shape a molecule will be
and and so you know if i take so for
example
h2 be and h2o now those look
right okay so h
b e h
and uh h o
h right i from lewis
we don't really know why they wouldn't
both look that way
are they both linear right are the ones
below both linear
how do we tell what shape they are and
as i'll tell you about today so i'm
going to give you
a way to do that and
uh and then a recipe another recipe just
like lewis
and then um um
we're going to talk about the goodie bag
which allows you
to touch and feel the shapes
you can't but like this isn't this is
we're going beyond 2d we're coming out
of the board we're going 3d
you got to hold it in your hand now
unfortunately we couldn't buy like 500
kits that are this big but i'll pass
these around because you can just feel
in these molecules
you can just feel that if i do this it's
a different molecule
and if i rotate that it's a different
molecule
and it's actually going to have
different properties right
and so that's what we learned today
louis
this louis this is just all flattened
into the board
it doesn't tell me enough it doesn't i
need
to know what those what how is this is
it like that
i don't know do the yellow things want
to be that close or should it you know
maybe be like that
or like that you see how when you can do
this i could do this for hours
honestly um and so that so i'll pass
these around
and i'm certain at some point we're
going to hear loud clanking sounds
of these balls falling apart they're not
held together too well please try to
try to not um and just play with it a
little bit
right and then your kit is a smaller
version of that okay
so how do we do this how do i tell you
what shape that should be
well we have a way to do this
and it's got a name even um
yeah so so just to contrast
louis is what we did last and louis
gives me the number
and type
of bonds okay
the number of type of bonds but now i've
got a way
that's called valence shell electron
pair repulsion model
the super visible
but see chemists are if i haven't
conveyed this before chemists are really
good at naming things
right yeah so let's say it could be
valence electron shell pair repulsion
model
it's not but it could be and if it were
we'd call it vesper
it would sound a lot better right and so
that's what we call it even though we
write it whisper
so we write it like this but we say
vesper because
this is chemistry
and this gives us the shapes now it's
based on
actually a very straightforward
premise which is that electrons repel
each other
something we already knew okay
electrons repel each other
and the stable
arrangement
i hear that molecule changing shape
makes me happy
same blow okay the stable arrangement
minimizes oh this makes sense right
minimizes the repulsions
okay that's really the whole premise of
vesper
vesper theory is a way it's a very
simple recipe that we will learn and
apply
that is based on this premise electro
we've already talked about electrons
repelling each other in atoms
right and in a in a bond and now we use
the same idea that electrons repel each
other
for a molecule right within a molecule
okay good but we need to rank order this
we need to rank order this and so we
have a rank order
and you'll see kind of why
um as we go but i'll tell what i'll tell
it to you right now
and i need abbreviations because i don't
want to keep writing bonding pair
and lone pair so i'm going to say that a
bonding pair
a bonding pair oh what's a bonding pair
well it's the two electrons in a bond
right there that's a bonding pair yeah
okay good so a bonding pair
to save time we're going to write as a
bp
and a lone pair what's a lone pair
well we already know that a lone pair
is right there a non-bonding pair a lone
pair an
lp okay good now this allows me
now that i have this very important key
i can
create i can tell you what the repulsion
order is
without writing out bonding and loan all
the time repulsion
order and this is what we follow
in vesper okay so we're gonna go the
lowest
repulsion is between two bonding pairs
bonding pair to bonding pair and the
medium
medium okay so the next in our list is
bonding pair to lone pair
and the highest
is between two lone pairs all i'm
telling you is
in this ordering is that okay
so okay electrons repel each other yeah
got it but there's an ordering to it if
i'm a lone pair
then and i see another lone pair then
i'm more repelled
those two things are more repelled than
a lone pair and a bonding pair which are
more repelled than
two bonding pairs and we got one more
thing we got to think about because you
see
the bonding pairs can be single triple
or
single double or triple right and so
those have a rank order which also
makes a lot of sense right so like
one bonding pair would have
uh uh you know a single bond with a
single bond would have a lower repulsion
than a double bond
which would have less repulsion than a
triple bond right so like two triple
but that makes a lot of sense right
that's just you're putting more
electrons
in the bond right and so there's more
stuff to repel all right so if i'm
talking about bonding pairs
there is also a sub order okay
that makes sense right so this is like a
a single bond
line two lines no room
three lines right
okay all right now this frames
the vesper model now let's apply it
and the rules are actually really pretty
straightforward so what we're going to
do is we're
going to build our understanding by
applying this
to some examples okay this is exactly
the same thing we did with vesper
with louis okay so i'm going to start my
recipe
with the first three ingredients passion
is always there too
but these are the first three
ingredients of my vespa recipe
first i write the structure we know how
to do that we learn how to do that
and then i'm going to classify the pairs
of electrons as bonding or non-binding
so i'm going to just label them
like that right and then i'm going to
maximize the separation between domains
and pay attention to these
rules and i'm going to start
a little bit of a table over here number
because we're going to fill this table
out number of electron
regions okay
let's do this oh you know when i do this
there's nothing but fun coming nothing
but fun
i went all the way all the way over why
because i need some space all right now
here we're going to say
electron pair geometry
and we'll be talking about this today
geometry
okay good
and then here oh okay now this
is sort of the molecular
molecular geometry
so i'm going from
i'm going from you know counting
electron regions and labeling what kind
they are
to a geometry of the electron cloud
around things
to an actual molecular shape which is
what vesper gives us
and to know why is this so wide well
because
there's options in here right because i
could have
no lone pairs
all right i could have one
lone pair and you will this will all
make a lot of sense
two lone pairs and so on
we'll keep going as we get there okay
so i'm going to start with very simple
case i'm going to start with this
right and then we're going to put some
stuff into that table as we go
all right so look if i have h
b e h then that's already 0.1 i'm going
to write just like i did with lewis i'm
going to write the number of the recipe
next to what i'm doing on the board okay
so one right lewis structure i did it
okay good now two i've got two
electron pairs right
okay and they're both bonding
both are bp okay
and so i've got two bp domains and as
you can see i've got no
lp domains okay
and so three this is going to be
max separation max
sep will have to be linear
just no other way about it i've only got
two electron domains
i've got no lone pairs so two bonding
domains two electron domains
it's got to be linear that's the only
way i can go
so if the number of electron regions is
two which it is for
beh2 okay and
and then the number of the electron pair
geometry
is linear
right because that maximizes the
separations and
there's no lone pairs and so it's linear
you say well that
really seems redundant well and it is in
this case
oh it's not going to stay that way
not gonna stay that way okay
good one lone pair no no lone pairs
i mean if i had two electron regions
total okay and one of them was a lone
pair it's kind of
boring i mean you know if this were a
lone pair here instead of a bond
well clearly it's linear there's only
two atoms right so that's kind of the
the simplest case we won't really talk
about that
good okay now is it the same kind of
thing let me
just make sure that there's no confusion
here and
let's not leave this up right yeah but
if i had
uh let's say i go back to my first slide
there
okay let's do so what if i had this one
it looks more complicated
right it looks more complicated so
now okay so okay step one uh
o and
here you go here you go
and there's a point i want to make here
because if i count up the bonding
pair domains and the lone pair domains
on this one
right say well okay i've got the the
bonding pairs here
right i've got some bps i've got two bp
domains right here and here
just like i did in hbeh okay
but oh i've got all these lone pairs now
right don't i have four lone pair no
and the reason is we have to pick an
atom
in vesper we have to pick an atom we're
doing this
around an atom vesper applies around an
atom you pick a central atom and i
picked carbon
as my central atom and then you apply
vesper
so there's no lone pairs around the
carbon that
that doesn't matter for the shape around
carbon
okay that's really important so i pick
my central atom
now so now i know there's no lone pairs
no lp because central atom
you know what i mean central atom
and then finally three we're going to
get
linear because again there's only two
electron domains
right there's only two electron domains
and the only geometry really
that you can take in this case is linear
no lone pairs two electron domains
good and now you know it's about to get
fun
because now we're gonna go to
something more let's go back to our
recipe there it is okay
so i'm gonna make room here
and do my next one
i'm going to go a little bit more
complicated now so now i've got
bf3 so b
and we're going to go f
f f
and we know we got all these all these
lone pairs out on the f's
remember this is one that's electron
deficient we talked about this last week
all right electron deficient so the
boron
is happy even though it's only got those
three bonds but the question is what's
the shape we've been drawing these
structures like this in 2d
what's the real shape right and now we
can apply vesper because
that's step one step two is that i've
got three
bonding pairs three bp bp
right and no lp
okay and so now if i have three
electron domains three electron domains
which i have
um then the max separation for this case
max sep ah max step
is going to be for them to spread out in
a trigonal plane
okay so that's what they're going to do
and that is called
trigonal planar it has a name
trigonal planar so
you know it's it's kind of
plainer so it's kind of right but it's
not quite right because i drew it with
90 degree angles and that's not what
they're gonna do to maximize
their spacing here right they're going
to go
at angles like that right they're going
to find 120.
but so if i have three electron regions
here we go then now i had three okay so
the electron pair geometry why is this
different
you will see in a minute the electron
pair geometry covers bps and lps
but in this case there's only bps
fine there's still only three right
and so it's trigonal planar
trigonal planar
and guess what if there's no lps
okay so the the structure that the
molecule takes of those electron domains
takes sorry
is a trigonal planar the structure that
the molecule takes if there's no lps
is also trigonal planar
but now the moment we've been waiting
for
is what happens when that's not true
and you've got a lone pair so again
we're going to do this by example
okay and so my next example is
formaldehyde which is something we loved
to talk about in
when we did lewis so c h2o
okay so the lewis structure for this
looks like this right we drew this
before
oh it's got the lone pairs out here
and then there's h ah
and another h
that's formaldehyde um
okay now hold on but there's no are
there any lone pairs here
there's no long there's no lone pairs
there's no lone pairs so hold on
if i go to two i've got
three bonding pairs and
zero lone pairs it looks a whole lot
like vf3
but it's different it's different
because now this
matters now this matters
right and so now yeah so now
i've got to add so it's like so three
would give you
trigonal planar right three gives you
trigonal planar
because i've only got those three
domains but now i need four
and there's four oh you knew there was
something else right
give more space to non-bonding domains
and to bonding domains with higher bond
order
what that's the fourth part of the
recipe this just goes with what i wrote
here
right so i've got differences in the
molecule
between the bps
so you know now that i got to give more
space
to this double bond single bond
repulsion
than to these two single bonds right
so part step four for this case is that
the bond
order is
important
and this molecule will bend
so the shape of the molecule is going to
be bent
it will bend because this i didn't draw
it this way
if i want to be right about it i'm going
to go like this
still not quite right right and this
this repulsion
is stronger than that repulsion it bends
the shape so it's not
trigonal planar if the the electron
domains give you a trigonal planar
framework
but the molecule itself is bent
okay and there's another example of that
that we could do
there's another example of that and that
is let's do it here
and that is if we had the lone pair
which is what i mentioned before so i'm
going to take another example here
which is so2
and in this case
uh-oh am i making a mistake i can hear
i can hear stuff did i make a mistake
no i see this i did
i do and that's wrong
bond order is important but it is not
under one lone pair
it is not under one lone pair it would
be under here
and it would be if there's a bond order
it would be bent
if bond order sorry about that
bond o trigonal planar
trigonal planar slightly bent look at
this
i should have just kept this
bent bent
because now i've got
look at this in this lewis structure
i've got
two bp and one
lp and finally we have the case of the
lone pair
and we can fill this column in and it's
bent
and it's bent because again it's the
same i go back to this as my key
okay so i did bomb pair bomb pair but
there was a slight
shape difference because of the ordering
of the bond pairs
here it's going to be even higher
because i've got a lone pair
actually it's a lone pair double bond
but it's still stronger than a bond pair
bond pair repulsion lone pair bomb pair
right in the middle is stronger than
bomb pair bomb pair
that's the rank order so this will be
bent
this will be bent so three so i've got
three domains
three domains and hold on four
lp more repulsive
oh boy repulsive
and so that gives me uh bent
trigonal planar trigonal planar
bent
okay did i get through that without
making more mistakes
okay now oh yes so
we're gonna go further than this which
is why
this is only the beginning
but before i do i say why does shape
matter
i told you shape mattered in the very
beginning
but why does it matter right let's say
isn't it just important to know what the
chemistry is
and not the actual shape why does the
shape matter and so i thought i would
give you an example
of that um with smell
and and i yeah right
exactly and i actually think we should
do this more often i
you know i feel like this is inspiring
we talk about stopping and smelling the
flowers
but do we actually do it and look at
that they've got
you know one armor on the other this is
a moment
you can't share this moment on instagram
you have to put your phone down and be
there to have this moment
and i highly encourage you to be
inspired by this
now smell and taste are actually related
and smell is um
you know it's actually a fascinating
thing it we can smell about ten thousand
uh different smells um
it's remarkable uh a dog can smell
between 10 and 100 000 times
more right so if you if you do the
analogy that people do with vision
we can see a third of a mile dog could
see about 3 000 miles
right that's pretty cool um
but the question is why do we smell how
do we smell
how do we taste and it turns out that
the way that we distinguish from one
smell
and one taste in another has to do with
the shape of the molecule
and so just like a key right in it with
a key there's not
it's all the same material it's the same
chemistry in the key but the shape is
different
that can unlock the door or not that is
literally how
our receptor cells work for taste and
smell
um this is a cartoon i found that i kind
of like see okay
shapes circles squares
right okay and some shapes come in and
they make happiness
happiness flowers and stuff cheat i
don't know is cheese happy it looks
neutral
i would get happy with cheese but anyway
uh fish for some reason but you know it
depends
and but it's shape dependent now the
thing is taste works that way too so
this is what's happening in your tongue
you've got these these uh these taste
buds we've all heard
the word taste bud right but what is
really going on
what is really going on is a combination
of chemistry
and shape recognition so
so the taste bud if you look at the
taste bud that's inside of the little
these little pores inside your tongue
there's a blow up of it
and so this is what the surface of your
tongue looks like and there's a little
pore
and there's little filters in there that
help certain molecules you know kind of
get in there
and what happens when they get in there
well what happens is you've got these
taste receptor cells
that are like lock key pairs they
actually
only look at like the circle or the
diamond and they can tell you which one
is which and that's a major part of how
we distinguish
from one shape uh to another and it it's
actually so
um uh it's it's it goes back a long way
why because shape and smell
are are literally uh survival
they are literally like you can you know
if you taste something and it's
in it and it tastes poisonous don't eat
it
you live right so it is
it is a very emotional thing to smell
and taste because it is actually coupled
to
uh to your very survival and democracy
himself
democritus democr our friend democritus
said that shape must be involved he
thought that because
things that taste bitter are sharp that
the bitter molecules were sharp
they must have sharpness to them and
like like shards of glass
that's how he imagined it and the sweet
molecules were sort of these soft
fluffy spheres right well that's not
that far off
from being sort of what happens a little
bit
but when we look at like you know
glucose and
and quinine we say okay those are very
different
chemistries so it might not be as
obvious
why one of them tastes so different than
the other
but check out this example this is the
same molecule the carbonyl molecule
that is called an enantiomer which means
that it has
handedness it's the exact same chemical
formula and the exact same structure
except for one is like this and one is
like that
that's handedness right and that
difference makes one of them taste and
smell like experiment and the other like
caraway seeds
right it's incredible it's entire it
means that in our tongues and our noses
we must have chiral
uh the ability to to determine the
chirality
it's pretty cool right so shape is
critical and this is one example of why
this is one example why okay back to my
back to my vesper recipe
now we got to go a little further
because
this is three electron domains
three electron domains they can be
messed around
they can be messed around right
especially in this table we're talking
about lone pairs or not
okay i gave you the example which i kind
of fudged in there with
a bond order but what happens if i go to
four
so if i go to four let's do an example
with four
if i go to four i need some room here
why don't i do it in the center here
okay
let's do an example of all possibilities
with four with four domains and there's
three really good examples right and you
know them
let's do ch4
so we'll do these kind of more quickly
ch4 goes in tight
which would be c h
never leave enough room on top and h
there there it is okay anyway
uh and nh3 okay so n
h h
h and h2o
now o h
h this is how i drew it on the first
slide
or this is how i drew it up there before
now the thing is that in each of these
cases
what i want you to see in these four in
these three examples is their similarity
first
and their similarity is that if i pick
my central atom
carbon nitrogen oxygen
if i pick my central atom and i look
around it
each one has four electron domains
right so in this sense the kind of
overarching
electron pair geometry is identical for
all three of those cases
it's identical right and it's
tetrahedral
tetrahedral
okay that's the electron pair geometry
that's exactly the same
but i need to now count
i need to now oh there's the recipe i
need to now classify the electron pair
as bonding or nonbonding
and then maximize the separation between
domains while giving more space to
nonbonding domains and bonding domains
with higher bond order
as we have now talked about so if i do
that
here what i have is four
bonding pairs zero
zero lone pairs here i've got three
bonding pairs one lone pair and now i
really get to fill in stuff in my table
because now i've got the examples
of zero one and two lone pairs
for the same electron domain cloud
okay so there's zero one
and two what and you can see in in
methane
okay the only way for this to maximize
its repulsion they're all the same
bonding
pair they're all single bonds so there's
not going to be any kind of funny
business of a double bond pushing
harder and there's no lone pairs and so
this is just going to have the
tetrahedral shape
that will be the shape of the molecule
that is the electron domain shape as
well
so in this case it will be tetrahedral
tetrahedral
okay but see now in this case
i've got three bonding pairs and one
lone pair and we know
because of the vesper recipe which has
oh it's up there i keep forgetting it's
up there
okay we know that i want to maximize the
separation but i got to give more space
to the non-bonding because the lone pair
bond repulsion is stronger good
so what that means is it's it's going to
be sort of like tetrahedral but i'm
but in one place there's no bond there's
just this lone pair pushing down
and so the shape that you're going to
get is called
trigonal
trigonal pyramidal
pier middle
okay because i've got because now that
that's just the way that shape looks so
this is gonna
i'll show you actually a picture of this
in a sec okay
of what this looks like um
and then with water we now know that
this will not be
the most stable configuration because
these lone pairs are pushing
on these bonds too much so water is
actually going to
look like this where these guys
the lone pairs can come out like that
right at
angles like that be away from each other
right and then the bonds are down there
and that's going to maximize the shape
of the water
i mean the the it's going to minimize
the repulsions that the electrons feel
in water and that
is back to the same name
which is bent so i've got four i've got
a different number of electron domains
but i wind up with the same molecular
shape right people see that
bent touch your head now i
know this is kind of small i've got
tables
that has have all this at the end that
you'll have in the slides okay so
so i know this is a little bit crammed
in here but the process of writing this
is very
very fun and fulfilling
now we can keep going but i want to tell
you about a labeling system that's
actually really helpful
so if you know
we keep going we kind of want a system
to be able to think about these things
and so there is a system again this is
chemistry
we know how to name things oh but i
promised you i'd show you that first
so here it is there it is i don't know
why i didn't click to that already
that's this right and and the reason i
want to show you this this is the um
this is from april your textbook that
you're all reading so carefully
and look at that this really brings it
home
look at that lone pair now you're seeing
it as the electrons feel it which is a
probability distribution cloud
that's the lone pair and now you can see
the lone pair wants space
it wants room and it's pushing down
on these bonds which are pushing away
from each other
right and that's how you can figure out
what shape it is
trigonal pyramidal that's trigonal
pyramidal
okay the molecule
now um now okay right as i said we need
a way to to label things and chemists
are really smart so we keep going
linear trigonal planar tetrahedral
trigonal bipyramidal oh
five octahedral six
don't get confused octa eight but
octahedral uh
uh is for six electron pair domains
right but we need a system to name this
and so the chemists have brilliantly
come up with
a x e now a is the central atom
x is the bonding pair regions and e is
the lone pair regions
x and e okay
and so if i go back to like bf3 well
this would be
oh there you go a x3 i say what is the
shape of ax3
i know i've got a central atom a and
i've got three bonding pairs
around it and no lone pairs that's what
that means
all right i could go back to so2 where's
so2
did i erase it maybe i erased so2
i did erase so2
oh i didn't erase so2
happiness look at this so2 would be a
x 2 e or if you want you could put a 1
there
it's a highly sophisticated advanced
labeling system
that simply allows us to keep going to
keep going without writing so many words
right but we know now a is the central
atom x is the number of bonding pair
regions and e
is the number of lone pair regions and
we know about our rules and we know
about bond order
right so now if i look at those same
really what happened to oh there they
are up there
if i look at those same ones well okay
look those are tetrahedral
okay the electron pair distribution is
tetrahedral
but because in tight um but as you can
see in these pictures
you can get three different molecular
shapes
you can get tetrahedral same as the
electron pair
you can get trigonal pyramidal or you
can get bent
those are the names of the molecule
right
notice those aren't the names that
include the lone pairs the lone pairs
are how you find
which one of these categories you're in
but those are the names of the molecules
those are really important those names
of the molecular shape
right now if i move over one okay so oh
there they are
names tetrahedral trigonal pyramidal
bent now
let's move over one so now i'm going to
stop i'm not going to keep on writing
everything down
let's do one last example so here's
trigonal bipyramidal
this is what happens when you have five
electron
pair domains again and i keep saying
this but i
i know that this can lead to confusion
later so i keep on iterating
or reiterating the electron pair domain
count
right the five here the five here which
gives us this
overall kind of electron pair domain
shape
that would be five there right trigonal
bipyramidal
that includes you know a single double
or triple bond
is a domain it's a bp
right it's a bp domain a lone pair is a
domain
how many of those do you have floating
around your molecule
around your atom sorry your central atom
and then you go down and you sort of
decompose it in terms of how many of
them are
our bonding pairs x's versus how many of
them are lone pairs so let's do
let's do one last example
and it'll be for five it'll be for five
right
so five
and i want you to really go with the
center again
i want you to really kind of get a
feeling for why this works
and this is i think a nice example um
if you had the molecule
if you had the molecule s
f 4. i'm giving you two examples today
that violate
the octet rule right because
chemistry lives in the fast lane if
you have sf4 you s is willing
to have an expanded octet
right as you go down in the periodic
table
atoms are more willing to live in the
fast lane
and break the rules s we've drawn it
like this
f f f
right we've drawn it like this violating
the octet rule and all that but still
being happy because it's lowest in
energy
and these are all my uh my electron
non-binding domains
okay now if i count i'm not
remember those aren't going to matter
they're on the outside i'm picking one
atom
a is s right
a is s in this case and in this
case i've got um you know
i've got okay how many bonding pairs
i've got five four bonding pairs
and one lone pair and one lone pair
and and so you can see right yeah i can
just look this up here
ax4 e1 it must be a seesaw structure but
i want you to see it
and this is where playing with these
models really helps you see it
because you know if you think about this
it seems at first
that if i had four bonding pairs and one
lone pair
why can't i just write it like this this
seems
like a good idea at first right s
and then you got a flooring down here
and then you're going to go out oh i'm
using a kind of
cool new notation here all right
and then you're gonna go did somebody
just say whoa or is that just in my mind
like that but i'm saying whoa that's a
terrible rendition of this notation
but this means see now i've got to come
out of the board
and for me that's challenging because
i'm not very good at drawing 3d things
and so we use these little these little
shaded in
kind of sticks like that and and it
comes out of the board and then that's
like the dashed one and it goes into the
board
right so there's one
that looks terrible
all right let's try one more time so
maybe if i just do
this f
f and this is in the same plane here
these three are in a plane and that's
going down
and you've got your your lone pair up
here
that looks pretty good why is that
better
than something like this
and now one coming out of the board
and the other going into the board all
right
and now this would because in tight this
would be my other
possibility you know i mean if i think
about it i think why can't it just be
this
these look i don't know these look nice
and spread out why not
it's the lone pair again it's the lone
pair
it's got to be because you know i i put
up there somewhere
that's now not there
that the lone pair repels
the bonds more and i've got more than
than
than say a bond in a bond but the point
is that i've got
three of those here this has three
one two and three
this has two this is a happier structure
right so i wanted you to so this is a
way to think about it
you're using vesper you're applying
these principles
right i mean it's just a four point
recipe
but i'm hoping that in thinking about it
this way and having the little models in
your hand which you have
um in this goodie bag that you guys
will also kind of have a feeling for it
so that yes you have the tables that are
written out much better than
than how i wrote them out and here's one
in the lecture notes that i'll leave you
right total domains it's very similar
notation
right structures okay shapes
but also that you have a feeling for why
this is the case
all right shapes and molecules see you
guys
on wednesday no friday
you